[Musique]
travailleuses travailleurs parce que je
m'adresse
ainsi vous parce que je parle de classe
ouvrière et de bourgeoisie on dit
souvent de mes idées qu'elles datent
d'une autre époque qu'elles sont périmés
mais qu'aujourd'hui tout cela a bien
évolué mais dans quel sens la société at
elle évolué et bien moi je vous le dit
elle a évolué à reculons elle retourne
en arrière et mes idées ne sont pas
périmé elles sont même de plus en plus
actuel on a pu croire il y à bien des
années que la situation des travailleurs
allaient continuer à s'améliorer peu à
peu et que finalement l'élévation du
niveau de vie serait continuelle mais
cela c'était une illusion savamment
entretenu par tous ceux qui nous
répétait que notre société était le
meilleur des mondes et que les
travailleurs n'avaient qu'à faire
confiance
aujourd'hui les conditions de vie des
travailleurs ne s'améliore pas elles ne
sont même pas stationnaire elle se
dégrade et pas seulement les conditions
de vie des travailleurs
car nous sommes menacés au travers du
crack de la bourse
d'autres catastrophes économiques de
crise bien plus grave encore peu à peu
tous les travailleurs ont vu disparaître
des éléments de leur niveau de vie qu'il
pouvait croire à qui la stabilité de
l'emploi
mais quel travailleur peut dire
aujourd'hui qu'il ne fera pas partie
d'une vague de licenciements
et quand après avoir été chômeur on a la
chance de retrouver du travail
ce n'est dans l'immense majorité des cas
qu'avec ces contrats provisoires
temporaire qui rendent le travail encore
plus précaire l'évolution des salaires
elle s'est fait à reculons les salaires
sont bloqués depuis six ans d'abord par
le gouvernement de la gauche puis par
celui de la droite quand on perd son
emploi
on en trouve un autre si on en retrouve
un que beaucoup moins payer le salaire
minimum
il existe encore mais pour combien de
temps les patrons revendique ouvertement
sa suppression mais il est déjà tournée
de tous côtés avec les tuques et lessive
ep la protection sociale mais elle
disparaît progressivement les
cotisations à la sécurité sociale
s'élève et les remboursements diminue et
au train où vont les choses ça va être
quoi
l'an 2000 quel avenir aujourd'hui pour
ces trois millions d'entre nous qui
n'ont plus de travail de moins en moins
d'espoir dont retrouver et dont un
nombre croissant se retrouvent en fin de
droits sans plus rien pour vivre
combien de travailleurs au chômage en
sont ou seront prochainement réduit aux
restaurants du coeur
combien d'entre eux sont ou seront
bientôt chassés de leur logement et
condamné otto dix ou à la rue et parmi
ceux d'entre nous qui ont du travail
combien doivent se passer du nécessaire
car pour ceux qui sont payés au smic
vivre avec 4000 francs nets par mois
c'est se priver du nécessaire
la crise elle ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
cela fait maintenant une bonne quinzaine
d'années qu'elle a commencé et s'est peu
à peu que la situation des travailleurs
s'est dégradée les travailleurs auraient
pu se défendre car ils ont les moyens la
force d'imposer au patronat une
répartition des sacrifices qu'ils ne
soient pas à sens unique mais c'est dans
ces années là que les partis de gauche
ont fait croire aux travailleurs que si
l'union de la gauche arriver au pouvoir
elle pourrait enrayer le développement
de la crise celui du chômage et éviter
des sacrifices aux travailleurs
et c'est ainsi que dans ces années là la
classe ouvrière a été ligoté d'élection
en élection pendant des années décisives
du début de la crise le patronat la
bourgeoisie en ont profité pour porter
les premiers cours moyens aux conditions
d'existence de la classe ouvrière mais
ils ont encore plus profiter lorsque
l'union de la gauche est arrivée au
gouvernement
car là c'est un gouvernement que les
travailleurs croyait favorable à leurs
intérêts qui leur a porté les coups les
plus rudes
il y a eu quelques mesures au début
comme l'augmentation du smic comme
l'abaissement de l'âge de la retraite ou
de l'horaire légal du travail qui
pouvait faire croire aux travailleurs
que leurs espoirs ne serai pas déçu
ces mesures coûté peu au patronat élus
ont finalement rapporter gros car ces
mesures ont contribué à lier les mains
la classe ouvrière a accrédité parmi les
travailleurs l'illusion que le
gouvernement d'union de la gauche et est
dans la bonne voie et qu'il fallait lui
laisser le temps qu'il ne fallait pas le
gêner et c'est forte de cette illusion
désastreuses pour la classe ouvrière que
l'union de la gauche a pu ensuite bloqué
les salaires justifier les licenciements
institué le forfait hospitalier
attaquant directement et de plein fouet
les conditions d'existence de la classe
ouvrière
il y a eu aussi et c'est au moins aussi
grave les attaques au moral de la classe
ouvrière
c'est un gouvernement qui se prétendait
socialiste qui s'est mis à expliquer ce
qu aucun gouvernement de droite n'aurait
pu faire sans réaction de la part des
travailleurs qui s'est mis a expliqué
qu'il fallait que les travailleurs
acceptent des sacrifices pour que les
entreprises fassent du profit et cela
même lorsqu il devenait visible que les
entreprises n'utilisait pas assez profit
pour créer des emplois mais seulement
pour enrichir leurs propriétaires c'est
un ministre socialiste bérégovoy qui a
manifesté bruyamment sa joie lorsque les
dividendes des actions en bourse sont
mises à grimper lorsqu un véritable flot
d'argent s'est déversée sur la
bourgeoisie grande mêmes moyennes et
petites mais c'est au même moment que
les restaurants du coeur devenait une
nécessité non plus pour mais les
marginaux mais pour un nombre croissant
de travailleurs sans travail et arriver
en fin de droits c'est un gouvernement
socialiste qui en un mot à déconsidérer
l'idée même que puisse être mené face à
la crise une autre politique que celle
qui consistait à laisser les mains
libres au patronat à l'aider à
s'enrichir par l'appauvrissement de la
classe ouvrière mais rappelons-nous donc
ces années de la gauche au pouvoir où on
a vu à peu près toutes les catégories
sociales descendre dans la rue
manifester
on a vu les médecins on a vu les petits
patrons on a vu les paysans on a vu les
mandarins des hôpitaux
on a vu les policiers on a même vu
les curés et les religieuses on a vu
tout le monde ou presque mais pas la
classe ouvrière qui avait les mains
liées parce que c'était le gouvernement
de gauche qui étaient au pouvoir et que
les principaux syndicats ne voulaient
rien faire alors que c'est précisément
la classe ouvrière qui a été attaquée et
violemment
oui nous les travailleurs nous avons
perdu du temps que le patronat a su
utiliser aujourd'hui toutes les grandes
entreprises capitalistes font des
profits exceptionnels
il est évident que ces profits ne sont
pas réalisées grâce à un accroissement
de la production et des ventes mais
grâce au blocage des salaires grâce au
fait que les entreprises ont licencié
beaucoup de travailleurs pour en
embaucher - et surtout - payer il est
tout aussi évident car cela fait
plusieurs années que les profits sont
élevées que ces profits ne servent pas à
créer des emplois
le chômage il n'a pas cessé d'augmenter
un seul instant et le temps passé au
chômage s'allonge les profits accrus
ils servent seulement à l'enrichissement
des banquiers et des propriétaires des
grandes entreprises
ils servent à financer tous ces rachats
d'entreprises par lesquels les dogues
bénédicte il pineau valencienne lemania
de la finance se disputent la propriété
des grandes sociétés et disons nous bien
que si la classe ouvrière se laisse
faire
cela va continuer car la soif de profit
de ces gens là est sans limites et la
seule limite c'est celle que la classe
ouvrière sera capable d'imposer et cette
limite ni l'imposeront pas par le
bulletin de vote sûrement pas pas en
attendant quoi que ce soit du résultat
de ces élections pas en faisant
confiance au moindre degré à ce
politicien retors de la bourgeoisie
qu'est mitterrand on s'y disent
également hostiles à la classe ouvrière
que bach ou chirac aussi platement au
service du grand patronat et de ses
intérêts mais dangereux par le crédit
usurpé dont il bénéficie dans une partie
de la classe ouvrière
je ne vous dis pas à l'occasion de cette
élection
votez arlette laguiller et ça changera
jeu
dit qu'avec le bulletin de vote on peut
seulement dire ce que l'on veut mais pas
l'obtenir mais c'est important de dire
vraiment ce qu'on pense sans approuver
une politique qui n'est pas la nôtre
sous prétexte de voter pour celui qui a
des chances d'être élu et qui de toute
façon se retournera contre nous et
aujourd'hui je voudrais m'adresser plus
particulièrement aux femmes aux femmes
comme moi aux travailleuses mais aussi
aux autres femmes car nous les femmes on
nous fait une place à part secondaire
dans cette société
la preuve je suis la seule femme dans
cette élection
aucune autre l'a voulu faire acte de
candidature est en tout cas aucune autre
n'a été jugé digne par son parti de le
représenter
je crois que ça en dit long sur la
société dans laquelle nous vivons
vingt ans après mai 68 et le
développement du féminisme qui a suivi
nous voilà revenus au point de départ au
des femmes il en montre tous de bach à
mitterrand en passant par chirac c'est à
qui montrera qu'il a le plus de femmes
avec lui à tel point que l'on peut se
demander si les candidats font la cour
aux femmes pour obtenir leur voix ou
s'il se sert des serbes des femmes comme
éléments publicitaires pour vendre les
actions de suez
on a été chercher catherine deneuve pour
vendre barre on a trouvé une championne
de javelot pour chirac
on a trouvé madonna et pour mitterrand
elle se bousculent dans le milieu du
show business et de la littérature
et bien moi je crois que les femmes ont
plus de bon sens et de dignité que cela
elle n'achète pas n'importe quoi
elles ont leurs idées comme les hommes
et elles se déterminent politiquement
elle aussi ce que j'ai à dire ou femme
aujourd'hui n'est pas différent de ce
que j'ai à dire aux hommes
oui je m'adresse à vous qui êtes des
travailleuses des femmes au foyer
chômeuse rentrer était à vous qui fait
partie du monde du travail et qui vous
trouvez de ce fait dans une situation de
plus en plus difficile car vous vous
connaissez les prix des choses vous
n'avez pas besoin de consulter les
indices officiels pour savoir que le
prix de la viande a augmenté et celui d
sûr pour les enfants et celui des loyers
et celui des transports et celui des
livres scolaires et vous savez aussi
mieux que quiconque ce qu'est ce que
c'est que de faire la queue à l'anpe et
de consulter désespérément les annonces
d'emploi parce que les femmes
aujourd'hui partage avec les jeunes
le triste privilège de fournir les plus
gros contingents de chômeurs être
chômeuse à 18 ou 20 ans c'est révoltant
mais l'être à 40 ou 50 ans c'est
désespérant
comme les hommes peut-être plus que les
hommes car sur le marché du travail les
femmes là encore on le triste privilège
de représenter le plus fort pourcentage
de la main d'oeuvre non qualifiée alors
tout ce que les hommes politiques
peuvent raconter sur l'avenir la
modernisation sur l'échéance du marché
unique européen de 92 les femmes des
milieux populaires savent bien ce que
cela veut dire pour elle plus de chômage
plus de difficultés - d'espoir alors
comme les hommes avec les hommes plus
fort peut-être encore que les hommes
elles pourront dans ces élections dire
qu'elles en ont assez et qu'elles n'ont
pas confiance
elles peuvent faire passer sur ces
élections le souffle de leur colère et
de leur amertume et elles doivent le
faire parce que rien de bon pour les
classes populaires ne se fera sans elle
travailleuses travailleurs
il y à une pression verte ou insidieuse
qui est exercée sur les travailleurs
pour les amener à voter pour mitterrand
pour exprimer leur hostilité à barrois
chirac mais voter pour la personne de
mitterrand se serait approuvé une
politique antiouvrière qui l'aurait
commune à tous voté massivement pour
mitterrand et sa politique
ce serait de la part des travailleurs
lui dire qu'il peut vraiment tout se
permettre
qu'il n'a pas à se préoccuper de
l'opinion du monde du travail auquel
déjà il ne promet rien ce serait lui
dire que du côté de la classe ouvrière
il a les mains entièrement libre et
qu'il peut se consacrer à gagner les
faveurs de cette petite frange de
l'électorat de droite qui lui permettra
d'être élu en faisant
de la paix sociale un de ses principaux
arguments électoraux mitterrand
s'adresse au grand patronat pour lui
dire que s'il est élu il sera capable de
faire accepter aux travailleurs sans
qu'ils réagissent plus de sacrifices que
ses concurrents travailleuses
travailleurs refusé d'utiliser votre
bulletin de vote pour approuver la
politique antiouvrière des gouvernements
passés présents et futurs
faites-en au contraire un moyen de
protestation à moyen d'exprimer votre
mécontentement
et si je vous propose de le faire en
votant sur mon nom ce n'est pas pour mes
lire ni pour me procurer un quelconque
strapontin dans un ministère même de
gauche mais pour compter tous ceux qui
sont dans le camp des travailleurs
car si je vous dis voté pour ma
candidature c'est pour vous dire votez
pour le camp des travailleurs voté pour
la politique des travailleurs
si vous voulez m'entendre à nouveau je
donne rendez vous à tous ceux qui le
peuvent
au meeting central de ma campagne le
dimanche 17 avril au zénith à la porte
de pantin à paris où je parlerai à 15
heures
[Musique]